all right 25 on your wednesday morning
was driving me crazy speeders
again
viewer cheryl writes hey they should
rename the 215 all the way from gibson
in henderson to cheyenne in the
northwest the las vegas motor speedway
practice track
the left lane at all hours a day it's a
roaring thrill ride for some drivers she
writes i set my cruise control to 65 and
if i'm in the far left lane which i
avoid like crazy i'm run up on i've seen
gestures and they're gone around me so
fast i can't even get a glimpse of their
license plate what happened to police on
overpasses and motorcycle officers
chasing them down please patrol and stop
these idiots
all right cheryl i'll pass your note
along but i can tell you that the
highway patrol folks from the nevada
state police they have talked in the
past about the priority of getting
impaired drivers off the road and they
do go after speeders
i'm just afraid they're never going to
run out of volunteers for their social
media posts highlighting the folks who
endanger their own lives and those of
everyone around him when they're busted
at speeds over a hundred miles an hour
and yeah i get your point about renaming
the road but i'm pretty sure it's going
to remain the bruce woodbury beltway in
honor of the man who served many years
in the clark county commission and was
instrumental in getting the project off
the ground buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone now if you
want to comment or there is something
driving me crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com